under the Democrats Israel will be
destroyed because Iran will have a
nuclear weapon and they'll destroy
Israel they will use it too
So when you say I fight I fight because
we have no choice we have no choice
and there's nobody else I don't believe
that knows
how to do this so it's really important
to understand that the way in which
Trump supporters are quote pro-israel is
a very specific thing from the
Evangelical Christian Community the the
viewers of this show okay the viewers of
this show support Israel not because of
any concern about anti-Semitism or Jews
or it's because they believe that
supporting Israel will precipitate the
second coming of Christ after which most
or all of the Jews die depending on
which belief system you adhere to that's
why they are quote supporters of Israel
and that's what Trump is paying lip
service to